as well as this video about season six
episode one we've got a new video out
now about the final episode of the
expanse season six episode six you can
watch it now at the link below
the final season of the expanse has
begun and episode 1 is called strange
dogs because season 6 is mostly adapted
from the sixth expanse book babylon's
ashes but the season also adapts one of
the expanse novellas strange dogs so it
begins with this girl cara on the planet
laconia remember last season a bunch of
rogue martians led by admiral duarte
went through the ring to laconia cara is
the daughter of some scientists who came
here years earlier cara grew up here so
laconia is her home she loves exploring
and frolicking with the wildlife like an
extraterrestrial snow white she sees a
strange dog-looking thing that she's
never seen before and she gives food to
an alien bird in the book she describes
how she once read a story about a lady
on earth who feeds bread to birds so she
figured she could do the same thing here
but this isn't earth human food isn't
compatible with alien biology so her
food hurts the bird to kara's horror
so kara likes laconia but there's a
clash between humanity and this alien
world strange dogs is about the
unexpected results of humans and aliens
interacting it's also an immigration
story about a kid growing up in a new
place and reconciling her family's past
with her future in a new home
we see alien structures on laconia just
like the ones on ellis in season four
and we see this mysterious thing in
orbit above the planet we know the
scientist cordozar is studying this
thing trying to control it and he has a
proto-molecule sample
on the thing in orbit we see the blue
glow of proto-molecule in the past
messing with the proto-molecule and
alien tech has been disastrous on illus
it almost blew up a whole planet in the
ring space it changed physics and killed
thousands on eros it consumed an entire
moon and all the humans on it but
cordazar and juarte are determined to
harness this alien power
what could possibly go
wrong marco inaros extremist leader of
the belter free navy continues to hit
earth with rocks causing apocalyptic
destruction
millions are dead the environment is
devastated the home of humanity is
broken
in the book we get a chapter with anna
and her wife and child on earth
struggling to survive under a sky dark
with ash
but many belters celebrate marco's
attack and join his free navy they see
it as justice that earth is suffering
because for a hundred years belters have
suffered under earth's oppression
this belter activist guy is the same one
we saw on ceres way back in season 1
episode 1 he protested against earthers
taking their water and air and he said
in season 1 that when a hail of stones
hits earth maybe then earthers will
understand the suffering of the belt
because now it's the earthers who don't
have water and clean air it's the
earthers who don't have a safe home so
now they know what it's like to be
belters
we see that survivors of palace are
vowing revenge because palace is a
belter station that was attacked by
earth last season avasarala had argued
that they shouldn't attack palace
because that would kill civilians and
turn more belters against earth they
attacked palace anyway and what do you
know the survivors want revenge killing
civilians just made more terrorists
earth's ships are defending the planet
destroying most of the incoming rocks
but for avasarala it's not enough
marco's free navy is growing stronger
while earth is dying the dust thrown up
by the rock strikes blocks the sun like
a nuclear winter killing plant life and
starving the planet avasarala says that
she never liked shooting stars this
calls back to season one where she
looked up at shooting stars and said she
worries about people throwing rocks
turns out she was right to worry she
mentions that they're repurposing their
atmospheric co2 scrubbers to try and
clean the atmosphere maybe those co2
scrubbers were originally used to stop
climate change on earth because the
backstory in the expanse is that global
warming made the ice caps melt and sea
levels rose we see that anchorage is now
an island and the statue of liberties
almost got her feet wet it was the
crisis of climate change that forced the
countries of earth to unite under the
united nations for governance and it
looks like they mostly succeeded in
saving the earth's environment until now
the journalist moniker demands answers
and accountability from other sarala she
highlights how dangerous it is that
marco now controls the ring space the
ring space and medina station are the
central hub that controls access to all
1300 ring gates all of the colony worlds
beyond those gates like illus are now at
the mercy of marco marco could be doing
whatever he wants to a thousand worlds
and earth and mars wouldn't even know
avasarala gets away from it all and
enjoys floating in zero gravity for a
moment usually avasarala hates space i
[ __ ] hate space but now she enjoys
the weightlessness avasarala always
feels weighed down by the responsibility
of governing earth of protecting the
billions of people on it of carrying the
planet like atlas she works so hard and
still everyone blames her for everything
from riots in kinshasa to marco's
control of distant space in the book she
fantasizes about retiring to some alien
ocean where she won't feel responsible
for making the waves go up and down
avasarala hates her job and her sidekick
bobby hates hers too but millions are
dying so they do the work that needs to
be done
the rosie crew hunt down and destroy a
free navy ship this is day
187 of their mission and there's a sense
of exhaustion and futility among the
crew amos suggests they should be
getting paid for this saying that
they're not soldiers questioning their
purpose here the crew are still grieving
the death of alex they're stressed and
tense with each other
how much longer can this war go on
they find a drive on a rock intended to
be launched at earth so holden goes to
disable it but it warms up to fire which
could kill him naomi tells him to run
but instead he bravely stays and hits it
till it breaks which is the same
strategy he used on this coffee machine
so holden almost dies and naomi is upset
the books talk about how stressful and
painful it is for her when holden
constantly throws himself into danger he
plays the hero and risks his life all
the time so naomi can never feel that
her partner is safe
holden realizes that he's kind of an
[ __ ] to do that to her and he
promises naomi to be more careful for
all of them is that a promise he can
keep clarissa mao is on the rosi now she
once killed a bunch of people and tried
to kill holden but amos made friends
with her and brought her on board
amos and clarissa work together well
she's learned quickly to be a mechanic
though she mentions she didn't have much
experience with this stuff in her old
life she used to spend more time
planning fancy parties as we saw in a
season 3 flashback but naomi doesn't
like clarissa and gets angry at amos for
bringing her do you think you can do
whatever you like now she asks
amos used to be totally loyal and
obedient to naomi almost like he was her
son miller called him naomi's 200-pound
homicidal kid but now amos has grown up
and he's become more independent from
naomi and he's got his own homicidal
follower now in clarissa so naomi is
having trouble accepting this new
independent amos with clarissa on board
and alex dead the relationships on the
rosi are changing everything's in flux
can this unlikely family stay together
holden discovers footage of the laconian
ship the bar keith being eaten by the
mysterious alien entities in the ring
remember we saw its destruction at the
end of last season holden says this
reminds him of the artifact on illus
which was a weapon used by the entities
to destroy the builders who made the
ring billions of years ago
so on top of their family fracturing
earth dying laconians having
proto-molecule and naomi's evil ex
conquering space they've also got
interdimensional genocidal aliens to
worry about
naomi figures out that marco's rocks are
being guided by a spotter ship called
the azure dragon if they can destroy it
they could reduce the threat to earth
and free up earth's ships to go after
marco this could be the victory earth
desperately needs against the free navy
belters but naomi has mixed feelings
she's a belter these are her people
they're fighting against her son philip
is with the free navy can she go to war
against her own child
marco's free navy takes over ceres the
biggest port in the belt back in season
1 episode 1 we learned that ceres is the
gateway for immense wealth and resources
but ceres was controlled by earth who
exploited and oppressed the belters who
lived there so opa leader anderson dawes
worked to make series independent to
make it a home for belters run by
belters and he succeeded by season two
doors was running series as an opa
belter station through long careful
management the great negotiator
outlasted his status as a rebel and
became a respectable politician
after season two dorse's actor left the
show but off-screen doors continued to
work alongside fred johnson to make the
opa a legitimate belter government in
peace with earth and mars the earth
government called him a friend
but some belter extremists hated doors
for collaborating with the enemy they
called him well walla a traitor to his
people
and now marco has risen up on a wave of
that violent extremism last season marco
killed fred johnson and now he reveals
his killed doors too
marco has wiped out the moderate center
of the opa and made himself the only
option for leadership of the belt
marco installs sandrani as administrator
of series sandrani is a man in the books
but is non-binary in the show and
they're trying to make a plan to grow
food for the belt because most of
humanity's food came from earth and by
attacking the planet marco has put
billions at risk of starvation
including the belt belt stations like
ganymede make food and the free navy's
been stealing some food from the colony
ships heading out to the ring but it's
not enough and unless they build a
sustainable system to feed the belt
quickly millions of belters will starve
along with earth marco is not very
interested in feeding his people and
dismisses sandrani's concerns he's more
interested in his personal vendettas
wanting to hunt down drummer and naomi
for marco this isn't really about
helping the belt he only really cares
about his selfish desires and his ego
marco's son phillip uses his status as
the great leader's son to get sex philip
has a lot of complicated frustrated
feelings about his place in the world
his parents and his need for intimacy so
maybe this is an emotional outlet for
him or maybe he just likes sex but
philip acts rude and entitled and he
uses people just like his dad does
philip's friend johan has a vest made of
alligator skin to him it's a trophy of
victory to wear a luxury item from the
defeated earth he says now that earth's
environment is broken soon there won't
be any more of this stuff industry will
collapse animals will go extinct this
could be the last leather vest out of
earth
to belters like johan and philip that
might not mean much they barely know
what an alligator is but to earthers
like us the cultural and ecological
death of earth is a tragedy the belters
and the inners fail to see each other's
perspective and that's what leads to
dehumanization and atrocity
marco gives a speech about how ceres
will be the capital of a new belter
nation
this dream of a belter nation was shared
by naomi ashford and fred it's a worthy
goal and marco says all the right things
but philip knows that it's [ __ ]
marco's not really willing to do the
work of building a nation he's not
really the selfless heroic leader he
pretends to be
philip does feel loyal to marco but he's
increasingly full of doubts
philip and johan hang out with a couple
of girls and brag about their victories
with the free navy but then johan brings
up philip's role in the attack on earth
philip stole the stealth tech that
coated the rocks and philip killed the
scientists who saw the rocks coming
philip helped kill millions of people
last season naomi told philip that one
day he will feel guilt for that atrocity
and that he'll realize that marco made
him a murderer
naomi's words had an impact on philip so
he leaves and wrestles with his feelings
rosenfeld tells marco the medina station
is installing laconian pieces we know
marco and laconia made a deal that marco
can rule the sol system and duate can
rule laconia so now it looks like
laconia is also providing some
technological support for medina
rosenfeld says they need to reinforce
the abutments so
what are they building in there
philip tries to get involved and says
the free navy must feed the belt but
marco and rosenfeld brush him off so
again philip is rejected by his father
and feels that he can't help the belt so
why is he here what was all the fighting
for was naomi right
philip doesn't know how to handle all
his feelings so he gets drunk and
harasses a bartender when johan turns up
philip starts a fight with him and then
shoots him dead in a stupid drunk
impulsive murder
philip has killed lots of people before
but johan was his friend killed at his
hands for no reason will philip finally
face the consequences of his violence
and how will marco react
in the book philip just shoots a
security guy at a club and the guy
doesn't die so the show makes it much
more dramatic by having philip kill a
friend instead
drummer and her family are hunted by
marco's forces after her betrayal of
marco last season she lures an enemy
ship into a trap with her ship the
dewalt which she controls remotely from
her other ship the tainan but drummer's
partner michio [ __ ] up and presses the
wrong button forcing drummer to blow up
the dewalt to destroy the enemy ship so
drummer loses a ship and all the
supplies on it because of michio's
mistake
michio is one of drummer's partners in
her polyamorous family but michio isn't
a fighter she isn't trained for war so
drummer decides to remove her from the
crew and leave her behind
last season drummer's partner serge was
killed her partners oksana and bertolt
left now michio's gone too
how much more can drummer lose to this
war
amazon also released an extra bonus
scene for this episode about drummer's
relationships with her crew and with
naomi you can find it on amazon prime
video by clicking on x-ray then bonus
content so season six of the expanse is
the result of five seasons of build up a
century of tension and resentment
between earth and the belt is coming to
a climactic violent resolution and
everyone's relationships are being
pushed to breaking point can the
families of the rossi crew drummer and
philip survive this conflict can the
inner planets and the belt coexist
without destroying each other and most
importantly what's up with the weird
space dogs there are five episodes left
of the expanse we'll release a video all
about the finale of the expanse on the
day the last episode comes out please
subscribe to this channel and give it a
comment and a like thank you to amazon
prime video uk for sponsoring and making
these videos possible cheers
you